bavière ans patrick in rassemblés ce
soir c'est qu'ils ont lu avec plaisir
comme ça enfin vous présenter ma tante
est quand même en train de me dire qu'il
va venir dîner ici avec sa nouvelle
copine et daniel c'est ça alors que ce
salon vient de quitter ma meilleure amie
sans aucun état d'âme enchanté enchanté
quelle je sais je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment il a pu quitter le
rhône ce que tu as fait extraordinaire
pour cette gamine de transport que
j'écoute entre il s'agit là compte trois
caisses parlant qu'est ce que tu as dit
qu'est ce que tu as dit c'est rien
[Musique]
il n'arrête pas pardon il n'arrête pas
de parler de vous on rit de la mangue au
monde
j'ai demandé qu'on met plein la bouche
mais moi quelque part tu n'as que lui
portait en elle la promesse d'une vie
folle et dans cette vertigineuse pour la
première fois de son existence
il venait enfin tout se révéler nous
aurions tellement la vie on va c'est sur
un csi n'gourma renard
[Musique]
il se délecte de te voir faire ce que tu
fais ce que je fais qu'est ce que je
fais du lèche vitrine du coin du lèche
vitrines et tu délires totalement il est
juste venu dîner à la maison pour nous
présenter la femme que j'aime la fin là
la femme qu'il aime